oh that can't exclusive
its power 98.3 TV male bootleg can hear
the big homie to change city boy in the
building hey man this is a you've been
on the road quite a bit dog like
non-stop the last six months or so homey
I was hows it are the reception bid you
know it's been well man for 120 to
another one saloon Drake salute Nikki
but that's extending the invitation and
opened their arms to their fan base and
me just being able to touch a select few
that I had been able to touch before
it's been a blessing man perfect timing
number one record out with no lie indeed
I of them on the way next week I'm
excited hey um you know a lot of a lot
of things in hip hop that a lot of
people talk about is the debut album you
know nan said the classic debut album
over a lot of people and they dropped
that first look you know a special um
how do you feel about your on your debut
album dog is it gonna be a classic I
feel like I've been putting albums out
with the mix and of course of course
addition to the papers are armed I don't
feel any pressure but I feel like this
arm as always it's it's a step up from
the last project and I'm believing
progression and prosperity so I feel
like it's going in that direction yet I
haven't peaked oh I feel like I still
have room to grow so I'm excited about
um you're on the cover of the new
complex magazine with with everybody
from good music um how's it feeling to
be rolling with that squad now man s
some of the most talented artists in the
world
good feel good I no comment and said
that that he's inspired by you and I'm
commons one of my favorite rappers of
all time to me one of the best to ever
do it when your stuff like that you know
unless you definitely notice doing the
right thing but how do you feel when you
when you hear that you know I mean I
think it's dope that's coming from some
of the god MCS of the game I mean you
know which few of them I actually you
know studied and looked up to myself
personally so I think it's cool that my
energy kind of rubs off and gives people
that inspiration just you know continue
pushing forward although i may get bored
sometimes two people you know i mean i
enjoy her i enjoy music so i can see
just be funny so many people want to do
with me and you're doing indeed man with
me just a posse what's this about you
know taking in that moment just really
like you to enjoy that we are blessed
man yeah sure glyph super blessed the
debut album based on a true story august
fourteenth is right around the corner
probably the most highly anticipated
album of the year um how's it feel to
finally get it out man like I said can't
come quick enough metal mario working on
my second project i'm just doing like
one step at a time though you know we
need to put this out you know we have
with two videos in the host of ready to
put out continue soon business you know
me continue you know applying pressure
to the game you know what i mean and
coming with ideas and stuff like that so
uh you know like i say off the days i'm
just looking forward to the next step
let me ask you a question cuz you're on
so many features you got so much
material it almost seems like every
other day there's a new you know you're
on something new that the day I pops up
on the blogs um it's stealing a lot of
those stuff a lot of that stuff I think
I'm kind of through
Eunice man so sorry I'm not eat people
getting this music my brother why this
music is being stolen oh I did see that
you were you were talking about that on
your timeline a couple weeks maybe a
week ago someone was promoting a song i
think it was i I mean i'ma say it was
wearing Arizona i think it was somebody
from Arizona who was put it put out a
song and then get on buddy no credit man
you know you all know a lot of people
know what it is it but it's just the
density to promote it like like like
it's your vision love and they love an
hour so loving I yeah I never even seen
type of thing or oh if I saw you you
don't have you know you don't have any
permission to take things a lot of
things that they're taking our stolen
you know me like even after that some
more things got stolen you know me my
first idea popped up both lose me just
take a couple things started I mean I
guess it's cool to be in a position
where people are looking to try to get
musically material out but at the same
time that's what kind of you know hurts
the game in particular because you know
artist knows what they want to be out
they know you you want it to sound right
how you intended it to sound I have
certain steps that I do before release
music that's why I'm where I'm never
unmixed my immunity
just kind of you know obsession so yeah
you know anybody the claims that we did
records and didn't pay I don't have a
list with me you know i will do anything
except give them credit say their name
and then if sometimes not going to indy
and Dean um are you ever afraid that
with so much material being out you
might over saturate the game i think
i'll try to be innovative and have fun
at the same time I'm really pick and
choose which reaches I do you know I
mean yeah I like the pic this one's I do
exactly i mean that's how you don't
overstretch work you said can't do
everyone but you know a certain links
that i can still use on other side scars
breath making the scars Papa stuff so
forth and so on sir some urban with Hill
for some urban you know I feel like I
kind of have online so yeah you got that
home that whole genre I'm being smartest
my pen a business meeting no there's no
disrespect to anybody but I'm our only
child I hear you I hear you um I think I
wanted to also speak with you about on
the debut album you got a few guest
features got Scarface on the album is
one of the greatest to ever do it one of
the most underrated MCS to me when it
comes to grip the top five discussions
um did you guys work in the studio
together not actually send them the news
is while I'm gonna roll you know I've
been able sit up come on man I know how
it is i know how it is but I was
exposing purchase yeah I know how it is
yeah me you know me but you know we did
we are the word on me yeah last summer
now after you I [__] the album comes
out August fourteenth everyone's been
looking forward to it man i can't wait
for anybody to hear it man everything
else i've heard is gonna be crazy how
many can you tell us how many to once
you got on the cool summer album I don't
know you don't even know it's so top
secret right I don't know
just keep you know Brenda make some dope
join us but I don't know I really don't
i'm gonna call me and just try to seek
it a happy it you know you never know
what yeah it's a big surprise that's
what I like working with you because you
never know a um your progression as MC I
feel like you almost get better each
verse you know what I'm saying I mean if
you listen to even stuff from like you
know the trap aveli tapes and encoding
Cowboys I feel like even though that
wasn't that long ago I feel like your
progression has just been steady and I
mean how do you feel like you feel like
you still got a lot more room to improve
their try to get booked and so this is a
book right this way perfect there it is
man appreciate the love butter so I love
to change power 98.3 true throw